Uh, first of all, uh,
allow me to convey the personal critics of Prime Minister Mooney.
Uh, and he has also,
through me, sent a letter to you, uh,
a letter expressing his thoughts about, uh,
the state of our cooperation, uh,
and the progress, uh,
that we have made, uh,
in recent days. And I will have long enough to give you that letter.
Uh, and, uh,
certainly, Mister President,
he looks forward to visiting Russia next year.
Uh, and, uh,
I'm sure that we will find a date
which is virtually convenient
from the political calendar of both countries.
And I would like you, uh,
highlight the progress we have made in trade, uh,
which is, uh,
in the excess of a turnover of $50 billion.
Uh, and we believe that this is something, uh,
which, uh,
whose potential is now only beginning to be visible.
Uh, it is, uh,
important, uh,
we give it a more sustainable, uh,
character and we discussed how we should do that.